North American forest looked very
different 300 years ago and it's not
just the rise of infrastructure it's the
purposeful decline of many natural
predators before European colonists came
to America the gray wolf population
looked something like this
but by the 1930s that vast thriving
population looked more like this in a
matter of a few decades European
settlers had trapped poisoned and shot
the gray wolf nearly out of existence in
the lower 48
today that map looks a little more like
this the gray wolf has been on the
endangered species list since 1974 and
those decades of restoration efforts
have recovered the population to a few
key locations though nowhere near where
it used to be but in 2019 the Fish and
Wildlife Service filed this it's a
proposal to remove the animal from the
endangered species list nationwide
arguing that the gray wolf is no longer
threatened a hundred scientists
responded with a letter urging the Fish
& Wildlife Service to rescind the
proposal saying it's way too soon so
when are we done protecting the gray
wolf
[Music]
in 1973 President Nixon signed the
Endangered Species Act it allows the
Fish & Wildlife Service to protect
certain species from extinction by
limiting hunting trapping and killing
when the government decides that a
species is sufficiently recovered
they're removed from the endangered
species list or delisted and they
release management of the species back
to the States
and surprisingly this is a lot more
complicated than it sounds the federal
government is pretty efficient at
listing species when it's the right
thing to do
but D listing that's different this is
John Russa tick who studies wildlife
ecology at Michigan Tech University in
the entire 40-plus years of the
Endangered Species Act there have only
been in the neighborhood of a dozen D
listings were far less experienced at
that the Fish and Wildlife Service has
tried to delist the gray wolf in certain
states before and was met with a bunch
of lawsuits from conservationists and
environmental groups the reason it's so
challenging to DES listen animal like
the Great Wolf lies in the law itself
the easy way to understand the
obligations of the Endangered Species
Act is that a species is recovered and
no longer requires federal protection
when it's no longer at risk of
extinction so let's zoom out on that map
from earlier with this in mind the gray
wolf is not at risk of extinction there
have always been a whole bunch of wolves
in Canada and in Russia so if we lost
every single wolf in all of the United
States even Alaska they're not at risk
of extinction but the thing is the
Endangered Species Act is narrower than
that the legal definition of an
endangered species is one that is at
risk of extinction throughout all or a
significant portion of its range this is
the phrase that has been heavily debated
in court over the gray wolf because well
somewhere around 6,000 wolves may roam
here many more used to roam here meaning
the animal only exists in about 15% of
its former range so in order to delist
the gray wolf we have to decide if that
15% is enough
the Endangered Species Act isn't clear
on how to define range when it comes to
the gray wolf the Fish and Wildlife
Service argues that the law could mean
current range they're satisfied with
that 15% especially because of how tough
it would be to reintroduce the wolf to
all places it used to roam many sections
of their former range are no longer
suitable due to human encroachment and
in places where wolves do coexist with
people living alongside them is
challenging I mean wolves are happy to
kill a cow or sheep if that's what it
needs to do in order to live and get by
and of course that's tough or can be
tough for the livestock owner
regardless environmentalists interpret
this law differently they argued that
the Wolves range should be interpreted
historically and that until it's
recovered in most of its historic
territory it should fall into the
protections of the Endangered Species
Act it's this tension the law that makes
D listing hard to figure out
still wolves have been successfully
removed from the endangered species list
in Idaho and Montana in 2011 and in
Wyoming in 2017 the states are now in
charge of their management and making
sure they retain a certain population so
in Idaho for example it's legal to hunt
wolves with a permit but the state has
promised to keep the population at or
over 15 packs under Idaho's law wolves
do stay alive but they don't have room
to branch out to new or historic
territories where they might thrive
which is likely what will happen if
they're delisted across the u.s. the
current population will remain stable
but the wolves will only exist where
they are right now not where they could
be or have been endangered species act
is pretty clear that when a species is
endangered it does not matter if we can
find why that species is valuable or not
the species is valuable according to the
Endangered Species Act just because but
figuring on a balance between protecting
a species and thriving alongside them is
tough especially when that species is a
long heated predator
you
you